this is a production of cornell
university
this is episode two season three of the
cornell turf show uh today frank and i
are gonna talk
about uh lawn and landscape uh
unfortunately we couldn't get our decay
itano today so you'll have to uh bear
with us the amateur uh meteorologists
here will give you a little bit of
weather roundup but no art today um but
anyway frank it's a beautiful like looks
like a spring day here in ithaca new
york i'll hand it over to you what are
you thinking here early in the season
are we ready to we were ready to start
doing things to the tour carl you know
first off it's so great to be back right
it's so great to be back doing this
stuff as
you know people who get involved outside
and spend their lives
working with land uh the the breaking of
cabin fever in the spring there's very
few things that match that i think
everything means a little bit more when
you don't see it for a while so i think
that's where we are and in the
background here you have some of our
great pal dan scheid here the director
of grounds at cornell some of his great
work uh some of the artwork that they
did some of the adaptations they made
to get kids outside uh during the
pandemic so
i don't have to tell you that's what
this was all about when carl and i
started it um i think yesterday we said
we were just like talking out into the
ethos because we just wanted to say
stuff but i really felt like it was a
small way for us to contribute and you
know it turns out over time we've
significantly generated uh an enormous
amount of copy in fact carl i was
thinking the other day i need to get a
film student to come in and just chop
this thing up and we need a you know
annual greatest hits i mean you go to
the youtube thing and all you see is you
and i with our mouths open it's
absolutely hysterical uh if you told
people what we were doing no one would
actually believe it
so it's so great to be out again uh back
in uh
end of february early march early month
i was out in denver colorado at the
national ipm conference and i was there
with
my massed up colleagues from the new
york state ipm program jody ganglov
kaufman who directs the community ipm
program matt frye in the community ipm
program works out of the hudson valley
alejandro is the due director of the new
york state ipm program uh taking over
for the retired jennifer grant and my
hallmate our hallmate carl uh elizabeth
betsy lam there on the end uh does
nurseries and greenhouses with another
palo bars uh brian eshenauer and and
it's so refreshing uh to get out this is
back you know again when we were still
in masks inside and now even at cornell
except for classrooms we're out of masks
in the buildings again so hopefully uh
you know cross your fingers uh you know
you see there's another
uh variant going around europe again and
you know that's not going to take much
time to get here but hopefully maybe the
vax
the vaccines and the immunity that
exists in the community will you know
help us with that so nevertheless here's
my pal carl
uh carl won the new york state amateur
this past fall i'm going to embarrass
him to no end uh it's so great having a
student a former student athlete
now uh making his way back into
golf and of course everybody knows he's
not an amateur he got paid to do this at
one point now he's just weasling around
and i hear he's influencing when
tournaments can be played so we'll take
that up at another time but for carl
carl let me give you a chance to give us
our lawn stat of the day
yeah so we've been doing this frank we
do a bmp tip of the day for our golf
webinars on thursday and i figured we
want to do something here on friday too
so so coming up with these stats uh was
just poking around and saw this recent
report out of rutgers looking at the
extent of turf grass in that state uh
and this data from 2019
says the turf grass makes up 20 percent
of the land area in new jersey and and
listen i've driven through new jersey it
it's not it doesn't strike you as 20
turf but again when we're looking at
these big areas a fifth of the state is
turf grass and if you dig down even
further into that
75 of all turf is household lawn so that
means uh 15 of the state is covered in
household lawn turf almost a million
acres of turf in new jersey uh that's
that's gone up eight percent in the last
20 years uh the last time we did this
sort of survey in new york was 2003. if
we assume the same sort of increase in
turf grass we'd have somewhere around
3.7 million acres in our state here now
uh 12 ish of the land area so just
putting in perspective you know the
things we're talking about i know it can
seem small 2 500 square foot lawn or
something like that but
man this is a lot of area that makes up
our our northeast region
and again carl you're from jersey so you
know you got family in jersey so you
know
uh the perception that many people have
uh particularly listeners not from
around here people not from the
northeast they don't actually call it
the garden state for nothing i mean once
you get out of that new york
metropolitan area it actually is one of
the great hidden gem states of uh of
this country and and of course as a new
yorker it's they're just great fodder
for making fun of so all and of course
half the guests on this show carla from
jersey
probably never going to come on anymore
anyway so let me get to the weather and
this is the way we described it uh
yesterday to our golf guys and it's the
way we've been hearing from the people
in the field you know the ups and downs
and of course the thing you got to
remember even though it's ups and downs
we're having less winter
right we if you characterized winter as
you know when our stuff doesn't grow
very well right
uh you basically look for the between
the frost free dates when when are you
uh literally between the average frost
dates
and we're getting uh 10 more days here
in the northeast and of course you see
across the country except for the
southeast and it's very interesting
take this up the southeast continues to
be
one of the coolest regions in the entire
united states now again just looking at
this uh we had the
you know top five percent warmest
uh
fall period from september to november
uh and in fact when you looked at the
minimum temperature a really good signal
of the warming world you see that the
minimum temperatures were the the
height of the warmth of the minimum
temperatures was the greatest it's ever
been right that is 127. that meant it's
the warmest period in the history of
weather record keeping for the minimum
temperature now it seems like an obscure
stat but then december came along
and it kept staying warm we stayed in
the top five percent in fact when you
look across the country you see
everybody was warm it was in fact
overall the warmest december in the
history of weather record keeping for
the continental united states even
though you know folks in the pacific
northwest and the north central states
uh northern west states to prairie
states west of the mississippi
we're actually on the normal side okay
let's take a dive and it got pretty cold
january was among uh the coldest we've
had in the top 20 30 percent of the
coldest periods we've had and then we
back on the roller coaster and it's warm
again in february so
uh we clearly have had this up and down
uh period that's sort of played havoc
a bit with the growing sea the winter
time and the transition to spring
now when you look at the uh average
temperatures that we're supposed to be
getting in march right this is the 30
year near normal
mean temperatures for march right 30
years over a 30-year period right
basically we should be in the upper 30s
to low 40s to the uh
low 20s right up in the northernmost
regions of the northeastern states right
that's that's our mean temperature right
the average temperature that we normally
are going to get right let me get my
shimmy and my slice there there we go
and so when we think about temperature
and we think about what march is going
to be like let's i mean we're getting
temperatures pretty routinely now in the
50s but just keep in mind even if we're
in the 50s and we're growing cool season
turf let me get my pens
we did this pretty good last year carl
right if we're growing cool season turf
right and it's 50 degrees right we're
only at about 20
of the potential for that grass to get
going
so i'm not going to necessarily tell you
to go out and fertilize you're way ahead
of where you're going to see anything
now this is the air temperature it's not
a complete assessment of what's going on
right and it's looking like the national
8 to 14 day outlook is telling us near
normal but our northeast climate center
uh predictions are indicating it's
likely to be warmer over that period uh
into the 30th of march so the season is
starting to accelerate we're starting to
accumulate growing degree days right
base 50 growing degree days you can see
that really tight demarcation right
across central pennsylvania the
metropolitan new york area long island
you see you know 10 to 15 base 50
growing degree days that means we're
going to have you know uh you know 10
day you know 10 periods of time
when it's going to be more than that the
average temperature minus the 50 for the
day how many do you accumulate that day
so you're talking about one or two a day
so you're talking about 52 53 degrees
for an average temperature uh over the
course of a five day period so you know
we're going to get we're going to be in
the 50s but you look down south into
delmarva into delaware and you really
start to see the growing degree they
start to accumulate now the thing that's
fascinating about this and i brought
this up a minute ago where that south uh
the southeast is is really slow now of
course we're not growing grass in the
southeast but this is the national plant
networks national phenology networks
spring leaf index right the anomaly is
it ahead or behind norm and what you see
is just like the degree days are
indicating that you're getting this
really warm section here right in the
mid-atlantic and delmarva and then of
course even in the even in the higher
elevations it's pretty warm but then you
see this cool period uh this cool
section
right in the southeastern part of the
united states very interesting it's a
persistent pattern that that part of the
country continues to have and obviously
it has quite a bit to do with the way
the jet stream plays out
now
you get nancy in the lawn and grounds
area i know it you got to get out there
the soils are wet we're going to talk
about that in a second but everybody
particularly in the lawn world right if
you're in the the world where you you
have to you know cover 3 000 lawns you
know
lance blast just graduated from cornell
last year uh this past fall and has
joined the uh teed and brown lawn
service in in connecticut applying
products to lawns they you know they're
treating you know five six thousand
lawns uh in a region it's really
difficult
to you know time it you can't run out on
one day for six thousand lawns and put
everybody's pre-emergent crabgrass now
right so you have to figure out how to
balance what you're gonna do but the
rule here and you're gonna hear me talk
about this a few more times over the
course of the season the rule over the
course of the spring the rule here is if
the earlier you get it on the earlier
it's going to be broken down and get out
of here right so this is the growing
degree day tracker at michigan state
university right that uses both growing
degree days and temperatures to where we
think crabgrass germination or
pre-emergent control needs to be applied
now i wouldn't do it based exactly on
this i would look at this and then i'd
go out and look at some of my areas next
to the pavement and some of my areas
that are are so southern exposed places
where the uh growing season is getting
accelerated because it's warming more
rapidly okay and and the best the best
measure of that is soil temperature
right
get a meat thermometer get out there and
get your soil temperature and you can
see particularly in the metropolitan new
york area and and that 20 of the area in
new jersey covered in lawns is is
creeping into the 50s as of a few days
ago but as you get further north you're
still in the 20s and 30s and a lot of
that is going to be dependent on
elevation but across the region we're
we're creeping well into the
mid 40s uh upper 40s creeping into 50
here in the middle of march
now let's talk about rainfall right if
we look at the last six months
and here you're looking at percent of
normal precipitation right how much of
normal precip did you get well again you
see this really deep strong demarcation
that cuts through the northeast here
where below it it was fairly dry except
when you get out on the ends here where
a bunch of these coastal storms kept
coming up and whacking these coastal
regions particularly the ones sticking
out here in new york and new england
most of this region in the delmarva and
the mid-atlantic the northern
mid-atlantic really sort of dodged the
bullets so they were a bit on the dry
side but out here where we are in
western new york um you know the hudson
valley the capital district well the
hudson valley actually pretty dry down
here towards the bottom the connecticut
river valley pretty dry and i gotta tell
you this area up here you know for the
three people that live up there it
really is dry
that's a pretty dry part over when you
look over the last six months now if you
look at the pattern in the last 30 days
it's pretty much continued to be that
way right just the last 30 days have
continued to kept these areas pretty wet
total pre-sipping the last week you're
looking at generally about an inch or
less
but overall when you look at how much
water is in the system which is how much
rainfall is there minus the
evapotranspiration you can see there's a
fair amount of water still in this
system right even these areas that are
dry
continue to have persistent moisture and
i don't know there's this dark cloud
over where we live brother that just
continues to keep us normally wet but as
i indicated here there's some very
interesting things in the most recent
drought map first off for those northern
regions there and right around you know
southern jersey you got a lot of sand
down in this part of jersey you got a
lot of sand in this part of the state
right you're along philadelphia you got
a lot of lawns and high-end stuff going
on here and this is starting to indicate
that we're moving into some pretty dry
conditions now this it appears we're
going to get hit with some pretty good
rainfall over the next couple of days so
we'll see how this all pans out come
next week when we start talking again um
but right now looks like we've got some
water it's getting a little dry but it
looks like some more water is coming and
of course the national outlook continues
to indicate we're going to be above
normal for the next couple of weeks in
the rainfall area all right let's talk
about temperature right
and and you know what happened to plants
in the winter and what's happening right
now right you gotta remember in the
winter time grass plants acclimate right
they got to be become accustomed to a
new climate so they get ready for winter
and then the sun gets further in the sky
right and now they're de-acclimating
right they acclimate sometimes you see
these funky patterns in warm season
grasses when the cold air settles over
the warm season grass and the part of
the plant that's preserved right that
lower portion of the plant is really all
that's going to get going now and they
you know the there they get hearty and
they have the ability to endure these
difficult conditions
and now they're breaking out of this
right now they're breaking out of us so
how does this happen
and what are we going to see in the next
couple of weeks relative to the green up
of grasses right because a lot of us in
the grounds area in the alona landscape
area it's it's nearest neighbor effect
hey how come that lawn's green and my
lawn's not green you know that kind of
thing so here's a picture of the bermuda
grass invasion that we're facing at
greenwood cemetery and i want to go
through some of these aspects of what's
impacting how the grass is coming out of
dormance
first off
wherever you've got a fair amount of
grass and a fair amount of impervious
surface or pavement that pavement's
going to get heated up and transfer that
heat into that lawn area now we've
identified this to be a significant
uh
explanation for why the the grass dies
along the edge of the sidewalk as the
sidewalk gets warmer at this time of
year and it snows 6-10 inches like it
did a few weeks ago this grass has
already begun to break dormancy and you
can see how it's greener along the edge
here break dormancy
and then it's impacted by the icy cold
water
with the salt in it right that then
splashes on it in fact if you look
closely you can even see what looks like
that scalloped splash pattern
along the end and again this has to do
with grasses near pavement getting going
quicker now this also is a good place to
look for knotweed good place to look for
crabgrass look good place to look for
weeds that get going sooner because the
soil temperature is at 50 degrees at the
end of february on these particular
locations now the other thing is
obviously grasses just have different
colors even when they green up right you
see these darker green
rye grass or kentucky bluegrass
varieties they are notoriously slow to
green up in the spring
right they are very very slow to green
up to in the spring we've moved kentucky
bluegrass from a real cool season grass
to almost a warm season grass it takes
long to get going and then in the
summertime does pretty well and a lot of
that was about developing
heat stress tolerance and summer patch
resistance right one of the things we'll
talk about as we get going in the season
is the root pathogens that will impact
some of these grasses but for now
if you historically have had darker
varieties in your lawns and ground area
you know lawn and park areas they might
be the slowest to green up
sometimes what you do in the fall it's
very interesting i was out in or at
oregon state a couple of weeks ago uh
looking at the out at the pink snow mold
field day and they have been doing work
with tall fescue which i got to tell you
i've never heard anybody say a kind word
about tall fescue in the pacific
northwest because rye grass and annual
bluegrass can be so competitive in those
environments there really isn't much
need for tall fescue up there but
because it's getting warmer and drier up
there they're looking at tall fescue as
a grass to stay green in the summer and
one of the things that they found out is
these light applications of nitrogen
like a quarter pound and
later in the season remember they don't
really get winter they can grow grass 12
months a year they'll get evapo a little
bit of evapotranspiration in the
wintertime so the plants will take up
nitrogen in those climates later season
nitrogen at lower rates will enhance
spring green up right there's no doubt
about the fact late fall end helps with
green up and growth in the spring the
problem is if you put on too much it
leaks into the groundwater right so
these well-timed late fall and apps low
rates in the october to november's
period where the plants are still taking
up water moving water into their system
they'll take up that nitrogen and
sometimes green up it
now the bottom line is you want to get
things going in the spring you got to
get the soil warm and once the soil
warms the microbes get going and they
start chomping on that organic mat right
this is the great beauty of the american
lawn of any that close-cut vegetation is
that seething foundry of
microbial activity
chomping on the organic matter right
breaking it down and as they do that
they release nitrogen that's it that's
why you don't have to fertilize in the
spring generally because once those
soils get going they're gonna and if
they're wet right and if they're wet
they're going to really supply the
nitrogen that the plant needs now
sometimes the best looking areas at this
time of year
are the wet areas because the water is
hit by the sun is able to hold the heat
and transfer it into the soil and
sometimes you see the grass growing in
the bottom of a roadside ditch because
it's wet the sun hits it just like when
the sun beats on the pavement and that
heat gets transferred
heat hot moves to cold right it's hot
moves to cold so it gets warm and then
it penetrates into the soil now of
course you're also going to get some of
this now i'm not seeing or hearing
widespread reports of these problems but
i have heard people say with some new
tall fescue areas that they do see the
little a little bit of this in the
spring in general it tends to grow out
of it fairly rapidly
unfortunately what sometimes fills in
there are wheat right so you might see
these early spring lesser celandine
chickweed the winter annuals right
here's an example of a chickweed so
direct your attention to our uh weed id
website maintained by our weed extension
program right nice and easy you don't
need to know a lot you should be able to
look at this and work your way through
how to identify a particular grass a
weed
and again back to the idea of
pre-emerging crabgrass let me remind you
our our recommendations on our website
our cornell guidelines even from many
years ago that haven't been redone now
for a number of years still have this
valuable information
right that if you put down a
pre-emergent material early right and
you're looking for 12 to 15 week control
you're looking for the ease right you're
looking for the ease if you're going out
with just baylan or team uh here's team
this is treflan
none of these are going to be as good as
barricade as dithiopia as pender methyl
so if you're trying to get it down early
um you know you're this is the amount of
time you're going to get under ideal
conditions
you're likely to see and this is
something we're starting to see more and
more of as as the climate becomes
favorable in the fall right it was
really warm very late so that allows you
know soil animals soil grow you know you
know
white grub species the four or five that
we have
to continue to develop and actually egg
lane
gets prolonged right it was a bit dry at
times
there was an opportunity for them to
expand their egg laying period so you
are going to find multiple instars right
so when you look for white grub species
right first in star second instar
third in star
run in the house in star right take over
the house but
what i'm saying is you know these are
the two stages you need to target for
the non-chemical uh nematode use right i
don't think we've seen much nematode use
in the spring but these uh entomophagus
nematodes they're really effective on
these
lower these smaller uh grubs in general
we don't recommend an insecticide in the
spring typically because they're
normally this big and and mike valani
passed away many years ago
published a study once that showed you
needed something like 10 times the
active ingredient uh in the labeled rate
to kill a third instar grub right so
get to this website you spend your time
looking at the anal slits of these grubs
and make your friends think you're cool
or probably make a meme out of this at
some point and and get a handle on these
soil insects and try to avoid uh
indiscriminate insecticide use right
because i don't have to tell you about
the pollinators we'll get to that a
little bit later
we haven't had a conference call yet
with our extension staff across the
northeastern united states
last year this was a big topic so i'm
waiting to see if it's going to be a
topic again and of course we've got some
resources that you can access uh to
learn more about that so carl here we
are we got any questions uh or other
things we want to chat about uh before
we wrap up in the next few minutes yeah
i think one of the notes you're hitting
on frank is early in the season we start
to see this nice weather we see certain
areas greening up we want to do
something but if i'm correct and and
hearing what you're saying you're saying
really it's a great time to observe some
of these
micro climate differences uh yard to
yard or even spaces within your yard
is that the thing you'd say you know
first thing
before you start touching a piece of
equipment or or thinking about
fertilizer or whatever would you say
that's the first thing people should do
when when they're getting out on lancers
yeah yeah for sure now that's a very
good point carl because here's what i
can tell you know in my years in the
landscape business i'll be it was in the
70s uh and what i watch around campus
and and when i get to you know
communities where landscape crews and
grounds crews are out
generally this is a go around pick up
stick time
this is like it could snow a foot again
up here right and you know down in new
york and a lot of places are still wet
so i think everybody's really mindful of
you know not getting on the lawns too
much
um getting around with a rake picking up
some sticks raking up some areas
i like patching in some seed
you know it's not a bad time to go
around but your point about
observing looking at your microclimate
differences and i brought that up with
the southwest space you know the
southern facing areas near the pavements
right the unique microclimates that make
up and characterize the urban
environment where most of our grass is
right i mean listen we're in ithaca it's
the middle of friggin nowhere but we got
a little city here there's pavement
everywhere on the several hundred acres
that make up this campus so it literally
is an urban environment so you're
exactly right carl look for these things
because
consider
i may get crabgrass there sooner maybe i
should get out there now and just expect
to
spot treat if i get any escapes later in
the year right instead of saying i'm
gonna blanket everything
and then it wears out and you like i
gotta blanket it again or the whole
place is full of crabgrass you know what
i mean i i think the these site
differences that we're beginning to
identify
if you've got the resources to do it get
out there look around clean up make some
notes same on the grounds my experiences
that's what's happening
it would be really good you know you and
i should probably think about what is a
spring checklist that we'd send our
crews out with what are the kinds of
things they should be looking at where
are your south facing slopes what have
you noticed just looking at green up
have a place to take a picture and say
here's what it looks like on this date
in 2022.
you do that every 40 every year for five
years you're gonna have a pretty good
sense and a good story to tell a lot of
what i've realized carl is all of these
folks working in lawns and grounds got
to get better all the time and talking
to people about what they do because
they see them
because they see them
yeah and the one thing i'll note frank
is you talk about cleaning up and and
certainly in the lawn area there's
probably excess i'm looking at my own
lawn right now there's leaves hanging
around there's sticks that fall down um
but new york state ipm just tweeted out
and joellen i know you're here with us
live but in garden beds if you see it
kind of looking raggedy that's actually
okay for pollinator habitat earlier in
the year so if you're getting the itch
to maybe clean up those areas but you
like to have some pollinators around
that's some good habitat for them to
kind of hang out in early in the season
so you know don't get too quick to start
cleaning up those garden beds and start
prepping them because there's some good
space in there for
the beneficial bugs around us uh well
you know that's interesting because um i
almost stuck the slide in about leaf
litter and ticks
you know carl it's double-edged sword
i'm so glad we have joellen uh here and
you know of course we're at our 30
minutes but we're going to take this up
again because it is a conundrum right
along wooded edges that might be more
those kinds of habitats we might want to
be careful but maybe in places where
they're pollinators uh we might think of
these things strategically this is
really the important uh what did what
did she say it depends right the great
extension answer right all right so carl
we're at 10 30. any last thoughts before
we get out of here
i think that's a great way to wrap it up
a bit of an ominous ending ticks you
know the danger word takes we'll be back
we'll be back so
thanks everyone for joining this week
we'll be back next thursday with our
golf show and and friday with a sports
turf show take care
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu